let's just talk about the mayor of
london for a second the mayor of london
talks about body positivity he talks
about masks he talks about feminism and
he bangs on about trump and he bangs on
about austerity it's so debilitating
it's so disempowering i interviewed the
mayor of miami and afterwards you are
not going to walk away without feeling
empowered i was like wow i felt so
excited and ultimately you know coming
to miami like my business has just grown
not many of my clients are in miami but
like my mentality is just expanding and
i want to you know charge higher prices
offer more value that is just because of
the energy that's instilled here and
that energy comes from the top right it
comes from the mayor there was a a woman
on the london underground there was a
big poster and she was wearing a bikini
and she looked gorgeous and it was like
beach body ready and we had to have that
taken down because it offended
overweight people the mayor of london
decided to take down a healthy looking
woman because it offended fat people